um so firstly we've got hearing solution
for one a are you happy with this for a
-12 for a - off so what he has done is
he's multiplying and I like to I often
like to do this even on my book so that
I can see they're working I have this
for and it multiplies to the first thing
inside the brackets and it also
multiplies to the second thing we call
this the distributive law because that
multiplication by four it's sort of
distributes to everyone okay and that's
what we have the for lots of a and this
is for lots of yeah minus three I guess
which is write a minus sign comes along
for the ride okay and this one here we
haven't seen many of them like this but
you can see what I did here how the four
distributes to everything inside the
brackets well this three it is also
going to distribute to everything inside
the bracket so first it goes to the 4x
that's three lots of four X 12 X there
and the three also distributes to the Y
there it is and lastly it distributes to
the minus eight are you happy with that
thumbs up okay great now this last one
here I deliberately you know I like to
throw curve balls at you at the end I
gave you one so you can just kind of get
into straight away and then I like to
see what are you going to do with this
one now the first question I have is
what do y'all think of this working so
here hearing looks suspicious okay is
anyone else suspicious wherever else is
an may you've got some different ideas
who got who got a different answer to
this I don't wanna know what it is yet I
just want to know who got a different
answer
one two okay this the way less than half
the class so I want us to think about
this right one of the great things about
having working is I can look at this and
without even asking the person who
placed it here I can work out what the
person was thinking by looking at the
working they've done here okay now the
first thing that I think I saw actually
be written down with these lengths here
okay now if these are indeed 10
centimeters 10 centimeters if that were
true let's just forget about whether it
is or not would you agree with this
result that would be the area wouldn't
it okay so if this is true then this
follows okay but then the question
becomes is it true if so why and if not
why not
does anyone have any
what's on that for me what do you think
you desert so one of the things we do
know about this shape is it's a square
and one of the main things about a
square is that all of the lengths are
the same but you have to be kind of
careful with life what does all of the
legs mean there are four lengths that in
a square are the same which four legs
are they curve yeah it's the sides right
so this is a side up here and over here
and then these guys here which would
mean that they're equal to each other
right but this guy crossed the middle is
that one of the sides the answers in
this case no right in fact that's why we
call it the diagonal which literally
means going across something in a circle
we record the diameter cuz diamonds
across right so in fact these lanes are
not going to match this one and in fact
you can check this out yourself just
draw on your page and this for this use
a ruler okay you may have already done
this which is great draw any square you
like a t-square you like your links can
be anything just so long as it is
actually a square for your grid paper
that makes it even easier and then I
want you to measure what that length is
okay the length whatever you know
however tall or wide you make your
square you will need a ruler for this
part right once you measure that out in
fact I'm gonna do the same because I've
got a ruler up here once you do that can
you just Mulkey and however tall have a
wide how big your square is okay my one
look upside down my square happens to be
nine centimeters tall so it's probably a
little larger than the square you have
on your page okay now once you've done
that I then also want you to take your
ruler and now can you measure the
diagonal just go ahead and measure that
length can you do that when we get a
ruler out you'll need a ruler and go
ahead and place it all the way from
corner to corner oh I'm liking the roof
you
okay now in every case even though we've
all drawn different sized squares what
you should find is that height or width
whichever one as compared to the
diagonal I expect they're going to be
different has anyone measured both of
those for me
Louise what legs did you get for the
side and then the Dana
yep and one and one point four okay can
I get someone else who gave me another
Li yeah yeah so you point five and what
was it again three point five 2.5 3.5
okay we're gonna give it one more okay
two and three so in every case and tell
me if this is like nod to me your side
is gonna be shorter then your diagonal
is that correct yep so I've got I
actually happen to have nine and twelve
so what we've worked out so far which is
not a very elegant way to do it but it
still is true we've worked out that
these are actually going to be different
legs okay so I'm just going to rub this
out just as a a fun fact right I asked
you before if these really were ten
would this be the area are you all
nodded to me right this is something
that we would call carried forward
mistake there was a mistake we made
earlier but then like you knew what the
area of a square was right so sometimes
it a question like this just because you
have one thing in correct doesn't mean
the whole thing is worthless right so
sometimes you'll see this little acronym
particularly on a testament marker
trying to communicate to you hey this
stuff was okay but something went wrong
earlier on okay has anyone else tried to
work out what these two lathes are an
eyesore ahead go up and down and you
like not sure or okay here what did you
get
okay so you've got a you've got a number
for me right away which is fantastic how
did you get that number fifty you're
you're saying it's half of what this
previous it said where did you get that
number from ah okay can I just pause you
right on that here before I get you to
continue then it's our he always use
Pythagoras right now this question
didn't tell you to use Pythagoras at any
point didn't didn't when he let's use
Pythagoras a few heads you were trying
calculator was getting confused okay
like I something something something
like three four five or so like that
okay which is not a bad way to go about
it
but as you can see it doesn't quite work
does it I hated what did you do you use
Pythagoras as well can I ask you a
question
how did you know to use Pythagoras like
I didn't tell you to I didn't even say
that there were any particular shapes
and there how did you know what what
made you think of using Pythagoras there
are triangles here I can see a couple
and we've actually got a whole bunch
extra what kind of triangles though is
Pythagoras use so forth yeah Jessica
right Angra triangles very good and you
can see what's the piece of inflation on
this diagram that tells you it's
right-angled yeah go ahead of a second
this corner here just kind of here this
is gonna be a right angle it is I didn't
put a right angle on there though how
did you know that it Louise yeah
fantastic so you've got you got lines
that do indicate it for you if we were a
nice diagram but even if or a terrible
diagram I mean I kind of freehand drew
this the key is that as Louise mentioned
it's a square every angle in or square
is gonna be right angle D okay so then
you can go ahead now how do we do this
we've got like a branch of maths that
helps us when we don't know what lights
are we can give it a name what do we
call that when we when we put a name on
something like a when we put something
where you don't know the number is you
put something in front a number we put a
variable or pro nebula from that right
so maybe you could have called that did
anyone give it a name a or s for side if
you liked I heard that and then you can
use Pythagoras on this right can someone
tell me what equation I'm going to use
an easier to read color than green what
equation could I write that
as s idiot that uses pythagoras yeah ok
wait sorry 10 squared right very good 10
squared minus s squared equals s squared
so this comes from Pythagoras how does
it why is this our statement from
Pythagoras what do you get from that
yeah yeah very good
these are really the same thing but from
two different points of view these are
the two shorter sides you square them if
you add that together you'll get the
square of the longest side right now
just because we're teaming the time here
I'm gonna take a bit of a shortcut
through here I think we can work out
what's going on here if we add s squared
to both sides add s squared to both
sides that gives me this can anyone tell
me what 10 squared is last I checked it
was 100 and I don't have I don't want
really 2's squared I actually just want
as was written before I just want one of
those s Squared's right so what do I do
to both sides to get just one of them go
/ - I'm gonna write the S squared over
here and that gives me what hyung
suggested before 50 like that okay are
you happy with that does that make sense
now just before we leave this off one of
the things I love about questions like
this is that's not the only way you
didn't have to do this by Pythagoras if
you didn't want to write we actually
hopefully have these extra lines on here
I just want to ask you guys see this
length here this one that I'm
highlighting in blue if the whole
diagonal is 10 what do you think that
length is there it's 5 how did you know
where'd you get that it's 1/2 it's
halfway across that diagonal in a square
not all shapes do this right but in a
square the diagonals does anyone know
the name it's that's going to be when
you um cut something in half doesn't it
bisects very good by just means in two
and set means cut like section okay so
they bisect that's the halfway point so
if this is 10 you taught me this is five
right well if that's five I think you
can tell me this length as well given to
me that like also going to be five
and another cool thing about squares
again not all shapes do this but the
diagonals are not just going to bisect
they're also going to be at right angles
they're going to be what's our fancy
word for that with such with a P really
long word when the things are right
angles they're perpendicular remember
that so if I've got these things at
right angles can you tell me what the
area of this little triangle will be
half what's the air of a triangle again
1/2 base times height one of the height
and the base here they're both they're
both five and five that's the base and
the height if you like 1/2 times 5 times
5 so that's that triangle how many of
those triangles let me just fill it in
there how many of these triangles do you
see in my square can you count them I
can count 4 right 1 2 3 4 so really the
whole square is 4 of these guys I'll let
you go ahead and check out if you think
that that ends up equaling 50 as well
okay